The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Mike Acton today
who has done a lot of
programming on cell and also
done a lot of game
development.
He came from California just
like this today and
[OBSCURED].
MIKE ACTON: Yeah, it's
really cool.
I'll tell you.
PROFESSOR: He's going to talk
about what it's really like to
use cell and PS3 and what it's
like to program games.
So I think it's going
to be a fun lecture.
MIKE ACTON: All right, so
anyway, I'm the Engine
Director at Insomniac Games.
I've only recently taken that
position, previously I was
working on PS3 technology at
Highmoon studios, which is
with vin studios.
And I've worked at Sony.
I've worked for Titus, and
Bluesky Studios in San Diego.
And I've been doing game
development, 11, 12 years.
Before that I was working
in simulation.
So, the PlayStation 3 is
a really fun platform.
And I know you guys have been
working on cell development.
Working with the PS3
under Linux.
Working as developers for the
PS3 is definitely a different
environment from that.
I think I'm going to concentrate
more on the
high-level aspects of how you
design a game for the cell.
And how the cell would impact
the design, and what are the
elements of the game.
Just stuff that you probably
haven't had as part of this
course that you might
find interesting.
And you can feel free to
interrupt me at any time with
questions or whatever
you'd like.
So just, I wanted to go over,
briefly, some of the different
types of game development and
what the trade-offs for each
one of them are.
Casual games, console games,
PC games, blah, blah, blah.
Casual games, basically, are the
small, simple games that
you would download on
the PC, or you would
see on Yahoo or whatever.
And those generally don't have
really strict performance
requirements.
Where a console game, we have
this particular advantage of
knowing the hardware and the
hardware doesn't change for an
entire cycle.
So for five, six years, we have
exactly the same hardware.
And that's definitely an
advantage from a performance
point anyway.
In this case, it's
PlayStation 3.
As far as develpment priorities,
development
priorities for a console game--
and especially a PS3
game-- development would be
completely different than you
might find on another
kind of application.
We don't really consider the
code itself important at all.
The real value is in
the programmers.
the experience,
and is in those skills.
Code is disposable.
After six years, when we start
a new platform we pretty much
have to rewrite it anyway, so
there's not much point in
trying to plan for a long
life span of code.
Especially when you have
optimized code written in
assembly for a particular
platform.
And to that end, the data is
way more significant to the
performance than the
code, anyway.
And the data is specific
to a particular game.
Or specific to a particular
type of game.
And certainly specific to
a studios pipeline.
And it's the design of the data
where you really want to
spend your time concentrating,
especially for the PS3.
Ease of programming-- whether
or not it's easier to do
parallelism is not a major
concern at all.
If it's hard, so what?
You do it.
That's it.
Portability, runs on PlayStation
3, doesn't run
anywhere else.
That's a non-concern.
And everything is about
performance.
Everything we do.
A vast majority of our code is
either hand up from IC, or
assembly, very little
high level code.
Some of our gameplay programmers
will write C plus
plus for the high level logic,
but as a general, most of the
code that's running most the
time is definitely optimized.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If programming is a
non-priority, does that mean
to say that if you're developing
more than one
product or game, they don't
share any common
infrastructure or need?
MIKE ACTION: No, that's
not necessarily true.
If we have games that share
similar needs, they can
definitely share similar code.
I mean, the point I'm trying to
make is, let's say in order
to make something fast it
has to be complicated.
So be it, it's complicated.
Whether or not it's easy to use
for another programmer is
not a major concern.
AUDIENCE: So you wish
it was easier?
MIKE ACTION: No.
I don't care.
That's my point.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's not as
important as performance, but
if someone came to you with a
high performance tool, you
would like to use it?
MIKE ACTION: I doubt
they could.
The highest performance tool
that exists is the brains of
the programmers on our team.
You can not create--
it's theoretically impossible.
You can not out perform people
who are customizing for the
data, for the context
for the game.
It is not even remotely
theoretically possible.
AUDIENCE: That didn't come out
in assembly programming for
general purpose but we'll
take this offline?
And there was a day when that
was also true for general
preferred cleary at the time,
but it's no longer true.
MIKE ACTION: It is
absolutely--
AUDIENCE: So the average person
prefers to go on --
take it offline.
MIKE ACTION: Average person.
We're not the average people.
We're game programmers.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So does cost
ever become an issue?
I mean--
MIKE ACTION: Absolutely, cost
does become an issue.
At a certain pont, something
is so difficult that you
either have to throw up
your hands or you
can't finish in time.
AUDIENCE: Do you ever
hit that point?
MIKE ACTION: Or you figure out
a new way of doing it.
Or do a little bit less.
I mean we do have to prioritize
what you want to do.
At the end of the day you can't
do everything you want
to do, and you have another
game you need to ship
eventually, anyway.
So, a lot of times you do
end up tabling things.
And say, look we can get 50%
more performance out of this,
but we're going to have to table
that for now and scale
back on the content.
And that's why you have six
years of development.
You know, maybe in the next
cycle, in the next game,
you'll be able to squeeze
out a little bit more.
And the next one you squeeze
That's sort of this continuous
development, and continuous
optimization over the course
of a platform.
And sometimes, yeah, I mean
occasionally you just say
yeah, we can't do it or
whatever, it doesn't work.
I mean, that's part and parcel
of development in general.
Some ideas just don't pan out.
But--
AUDIENCE: Have you ever come
into a situation where
programming conflicts just
kills a project?
Like Microsoft had had a few
times, like they couldn't put
out [OBSCURED].
Couldn't release for--
MIKE ACTION: Sure, there's
plenty of studios where the
programming complexity has
killed the studio, or killed
the project.
But I find it hard to believe--
or it's very
rarely-- because it's complexity
that has to do
specifically with
optimization.
That complexity usually has
to do with unnecessary
complexity.
Complexity that doesn't
achieve anything.
Organization for the sake
of organization.
So you have these sort of over
designed C plus plus
hierarchies just for the sake
of over organizing things.
That's what will generally
kill a project.
But in performance, the
complexity tends to come from
the rule set-- what you need
to do to set it up.
But the code tends to be smaller
when it's faster.
You tend to be doing one
thing and doing one
thing really well.
So it doesn't tend to
get out of hand.
I mean, it occasionally
happens but, yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in terms of the
overall cost, how big is this
programming versus the
other aspect of
coming up with the game?
Like the game design,
the graphics--
AUDIENCE: So, for example,
do you have--
MIKE ACTION: OK, development
team?
So--
AUDIENCE: So how many
programmers, how many
artists, how many--
PROFESSOR: Maybe, let's-- so
for example, like, now it's
like, what, $20 million
to deliver a PS3 game?
MIKE ACTION: Between $10
and $20 million, yeah.
PROFESSOR: So let's
develop [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTION: So artists
are by far the most--
the largest group
of developers.
So you have animators and shade
artists, and textual
artists, and modelers,
and enviromental
artists, and lighters.
And so they'll often outnumber
programmers 2:1.
Which is completely different
than-- certainly very
different from PlayStation and
the gap is much larger than it
was on PlayStation 2.
With programmers you tend to
have a fairly even split or
you tend to have a divide
between the high level game
play programmers and the low
level engine programmers.
And you will tend to have more
game play programmers than
engine programmers, although
most-- the majority of the CPU
time is spent in the
engine code.
And that partially comes down
to education and experience.
In order to get high performance
code you need to
have that experience.
You need to know how
to optimize.
You need to understand
the machine.
You need to understand the
architecture and you need to
understand the data.
And there's only so many people
that can do that on any
particular team.
AUDIENCE: Code size wise, How
is the code size divided
between game playing and
AI, special effects?
MIKE ACTION: Just like,
the amount of code?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it should
be small I guess.
MIKE ACTION: Yeah, I mean,
it's hard to say.
I mean, because it depends
on how many
features you're using.
And, you know sort of the scope
of the engine is how
much is being used for a
particular game, especially if
you're targeting multiple
games within a studio.
But quite often-- interestingly
enough-- the
game play code actually
overwhelms the engine code in
terms of size and that is back
to basically what I was saying
that the engine code tends to do
one thing really well or a
series of things really well.
AUDIENCE: Game play code
also C plus plus?
MIKE ACTON: These days it's
much more likely that game
play code is C plus plus in
the high level and kills
performance and doesn't think
about things like cache.
That's actually part of the
problem with PlayStation 3
development.
It was part of the challenge
that we've had with
PlayStation 3 development.
Is in the past, certainly with
PlayStation 2 and definitely
on any previous console, this
divide between game play and
engine worked very well.
The game play programmers could
just call a function and
it did its fat thing really fast
and it came back and they
continue this, but in a serial
program on one process that
model works very well.
But now when the high level
design can destroy performance
but through the simplest
decision, like for example, in
collision detection if the logic
assumes that the result
is immediately available there's
virtually no way of
making that fast. So the
high-level design has to
conform to the hardware.
That's sort of a challenge
now, is introducing those
concepts to the high-level
programmer who haven't
traditionally had
to deal with it.
Does that answer that question
as far as the split?
AUDIENCE: You said 2:1, right?
MIKE ACTON: Approximately 2:1,
artist to programmers.
It varies studio to studio and
team to team, so it's hard to
say in the industry
as a whole.
So back basically to the
point of the code
isn't really important.
The code itself doesn't
have a lot of value.
There are fundamental things
that affect how you would
design it in the first place.
The type of game, the kind of
engine that would run a racing
game is completely different
than the kind of engine that
would run a first
person shooter.
The needs are different, the
optimizations are totally
different, the data is totally
different, so you wouldn't try
to reuse code from
one to the other.
It just either wouldn't
work or would work
really, really poorly.
The framerate--
having a target of 30 frames per
second is a much different
problem than having a target
of 60 frames per second.
And in the NCSC territories
those are pretty much your
only two choices- 30 frames or
60, which means everything has
to be done in 16 and
2/3 milliseconds.
That's it, that's
what you have--
432 milliseconds.
Of course, back to schedule
and cost, how much?
You know, do you have a two year
cycle, one year cycle,
how much can you get done?
The kind of hardware.
So taking for example, an engine
from PlayStation 2 and
trying to move it to PlayStation
3 is sort of a
lost cause.
The kind of optimizations that
you would do, the kind of
parallelization you would do
is so completely different,
although there was
parallelization in PlayStation
2, the choices would have been
completely different.
The loss from trying to port it
is much, much greater than
the cost of just
doing it again.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: I don't know that
there's an average.
I mean, if you wanted to just
like homogenize the industry,
it's probably 18 months.
The compiler actually makes a
huge, significant difference
in how you design your code.
If you're working with GCC and
you have programmers who have
been working with GCC for 15
years abd who understand the
intricacies and issues involved
in GCC, the kind of
code you would write would be
completely different than if
you were using XLC for
example, on the cell.
There are studios--
Insomniac doesn't, but there are
other studios who do cross
platform design.
So for example, write
Playstation 3 games and Xbox
360 games and/or PC titles.
At the moment, probably the
easiest approach for that is
to target the PlayStation 3.
So you have these sort of SPU
friendly chunks of processing
SPU chunks, friendly chunks of
data and move those onto
homogenous parallel
processors.
It's not the perfect solution,
but virtually all cross
platform titles are not looking
for the perfect
solution anyway because they
cannot fully optimize for any
particular platform.
I wanted to go through--
these are a basic list of some
of the major modules that a
game is made out of.
I'll go through some of these
and explain how designing on
the cell impacts the system.
I'm not going to bother
reading them.
I assume you all can read.
So yeah, I'm going to go over
the major system, a few of the
major systems and then we're
going to drive a little bit
into a specific system, in this
case an animation system.
And just talk it through,
basically you see how each of
these steps are affected by
the hardware that we're
running on it.
So just to start with when
you're designing a structure,
any structure, anywhere--
the initial structure is
affected by the kind of
hardware that you're running.
And in this particular case on
the SPU and there are other
processors where this is equally
true, but in this
conventional structure where
you say structure class or
whatever and you have
domain-constrained structures
are of surprisingly
little use.
In general, the data is either
compressed or is in a stram or
is in blocks.
It's sort of based on type,
which means that there's no
fixed size struct that you
could define anyway.
So as a general rule, the
structure of the data is
defined within the
code as opposed
to in a struct somewhere.
And that's really to get the
performance from the data, you
group things of similar type
together rather than for
example, on SPU, having flags
that say this is of type A and
this is of type B. Any flag
implies a branch, which is--
I'm sure you all know at this
point-- is really poor
performing on SPU.
So basically, pull flags out,
resort everything and then
move things in streams. And all
of these types are going
to be of varying sizes.
In which case there's very
little point to define those
structures in the first place
because you can't change them.
And the fact that you're
accessing data
in quadwords anyway.
You're always either loading and
storing in quadwords, not
on scalars, so having scalar
fields in a structure is sort
of pointless.
So again, only SPU generally
speaking
structures are of much use.
When you go to define structures
in general you need
to consider things like the
cache, the TLB, how that's
going to affect you're reading
out of the structure or
writing to the structure.
More to the point of you cannot
just assume that if
you've written some data
definition that you can port
it to another platform.
It's very easy to be poorly, a
performing platform to platform.
In this case, when we design
structures you have to
consider the fundamental
units of the cell.
The cache line is a fundamental
unit of the cell.
Basically, you want to define
things in terms of
128 bytes of wide.
What can you fit in there
because you read one you read
them all, so you want to pack
as much as possible into 128
bytes and just deal with that
as a fundamental unit.
16 bytes, of course, you're
doing load and stores through
quadword load and store.
So you don't want to have little
scalar bits in there
that you're shuffling around.
Just deal with it
as a quadword.
And don't deal with anything
smaller than that.
So basically the minimum working
sizes, in practice,
would be 4 by 128 bits wide
and you can split that up
regularly however you want.
So to that point I think--
here's an example--
I want to talk about
a vector class.
Vector class js usually the
first thing a programmer will
jump onto when they might want
to make something for games.
But in real life, it's probably
the most useless
thing you could ever write.
It doesn't actually
do anything.
We have these, we know the
instruction set, it's already
in quadwords.
We know the loads and stores,
we've already designed your
data so it fits properly.
This doesn't give us anything.
And it potentially makes
things worse.
Allowing component access to a
quadword, especially on the
PPU is ridiculously bad.
In practice, if you allow
component access, high-level
programs will use component
access.
So if you have a vector class
that says get x, get y,
whatever, somebody somewhere
is going to use it, which
means the performance of the
whole thing just drops and
it's impossible to optimize.
So as a general rule, you pick
your fundamental unit.
In this case, the 4 by 128 bit
unit that I was talking about
and you don't define anything
smaller than that.
Everything is packed into
a unit about that size.
And yes, in practice there'll
be some wasted space at the
beginning or end of streams of
data, groups of data, but it
doesn't make much difference.
You're going to have that wasted
space if you are--
you're going to have much more
than that in wasted space if
you're using dynamic memory,
for example, which
when I get to it--
I don't recommend
you use either.
So some things to consider when
you're doing this sort of
math transformation anyway is,
are you going to do floats,
double, fixed point?
I mean, doubles write out.
There's no point.
Regardless of the speed on the
SPU of a double, there's no
value in it for games.
We have known data, so if we
need to we can renormalize a
group of around a point and
get into the range of a
floating point.
It's a nonissue.
So there's no reason to waste
the space in a double at all,
unless it was actually faster,
which it isn't.
So we don't use it.
Sort of the only real
problematic thing with the SPU
floating point is its format
and not supporting
denormalized numbers becomes
problematic, but again, you
can work around it by
renormalizing your numbers
within a known range so that it
won't to get to the point
where it needs to
denormalize--
at least for the work that
you're actually doing.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: Every program will
write its own vector class.
And I'm saying that that's
a useless exercise.
Don't bother doing it.
Don't use anybody
else's either.
If you're writing
for the cell--
if you're writing in C you
have the SI intrinsics.
They're already in quadwords,
you can do everything you want
to do and you're not restricted
by this sort of
concept of what a vector is.
If you want to deal with,
especially on the SPU where
you can freely deal with them
as integers or floats or
whatever seamlessly without
cost, there's plenty that you
can do with the floating
point number if you
treat it as an integer.
And when on either AltiVec or
the SPU where you can do that
without cost there's
a huge advantage to
just doing it straight.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: Well, I'm saying
write it in assembly.
But if you have to, use
the intrinsics.
But certainly don't write
a vector class.
So memory management.
Static allocations always
prefer the dynamic.
Basically, general purpose
dynamic memory allocation,
malloc free, whatever has just
absolutely no place in games.
We don't have enough unknowns
for that to be valuable.
We can group our data
by specific types.
We know basic ranges
of those types.
The vast majority of the data
is known in advance, it's
actually burned onto the disk.
We can actually analyze that.
So most of our allocations
tend to
calculate it in advance.
So you load the level and
oftentimes you just load
memory in off the disc
into memory and
then fix up the pointers.
For things that change during
the runtime, just simple
hierarchical allocators, block
allocators where you have
fixed sizes is always the
easiest and best way to go.
These are known types
of known sizes.
The key to that is to organize
your data so that's actually a
workable solution.
So you don't have these sort of
classes or structures that
are dynamically sized.
That you group them in terms
of things that are similar.
Physics data here and AI data
is separately here in a
separate array.
And that way those sort of
chunks of data are similarly
sized and can be block
allocated without any
fragmentation issues at all.
Eventually you'll probably want
to design an allocator.
Things to consider are
the page sizes.
That's critically important, you
want to work within a page
as much as you possibly can.
So you want to group things,
not necessarily the same
things, but the things that
will be read together or
written together within
the same page.
So you want to have a concept of
the actual page up through
the system.
Probably the most common mistake
I see in a block
allocator, so somebody says--
everybody knows what I mean
by block allocator?
Yeah?
OK.
So the most common mistake I see
people make is that they
do least recently used.
They just grab the most least
recently used block and use
that when summoning a request.
That's actually pretty much
the worst thing you can possibly
do because that's the
most likely thing
to be called.
That's the most likely thing to
be out of cache, both out
of L1 and L2.
Just the easiest thing you can
do to change that is just use
most recently used.
Just go up the other way.
I mean, there are much more
complicated systems you can
use, but just that one small
change where you're much more
likely to get warm data is going
to give you a big boost.
And again, like I said, use
hierarchies of allocations
instead of these sort of static
block allocations.
Instead of trying to have one
general purpose super mega
allocator that does
everything.
And again, if it's well planned,
fragmentation is a
non-issue, it's impossible.
Cache line, oh, and probably
another important concept to
keep in mind as you're writing
your allocator is the transfer
block size of the SPU.
If you have a 16K block and the
system is aware of fixing
K blocks then there are plenty
of cases where you don't have
to keep track of-- in the
system-- the size of things.
It's just how many blocks, how
many SPU blocks do you have?
Or what percentage of
SPU blocks you have?
And that will help you can sort
of compress down your
memory requirements when you're
referring to blocks and
memory streams and memory.
AUDIENCE: About the memory
management for data here, you
also write overlay managers
for code for the user?
MIKE ACTON: Well, it basically
amounts to the same thing.
I mean, the code is just data,
you just load it in and fix up
the pointers and you're done.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering
whether IBM gives you
embedding --
MIKE ACTON: We don't
usse any of the IBM
systems at all for games.
I know IBM has an overlay
manager as part of the SDK.
AUDIENCE: Well, not really.
It's --
MIKE ACTON: Well, they have some
overlay support, right?
That's not something
we would ever use.
And in general, I mean, I
guess that's probably an
interesting question of how--
AUDIENCE: So it's
all ground up?
MIKE ACTON: What's that?
AUDIENCE: All your development
is ground up?
MIKE ACTON: Yeah, for
the most part.
For us, that's definitely
true.
There are studios that,
especially cross platform
studios that will take
middleware development and
just sort of use it
on a high-level.
But especially when you're
starting a first generation
platform game, there's virtually
nothing there to use
because the hardware hasn't been
around long enough for
anybody else to write
anything either.
So if you need it, you
write it yourself.
Plus that's just sort of the
general theme of game
development.
It's custom to your situation,
to your data.
And anything that's general
purpose enough to sell as
middleware is probably not going
to be fast enough to run
a triple A title.
Not always true, but
as a general
rule, it's pretty valid.
OK, so-- wait, so how'd
I get here?
All right, this is next.
So here's another example
of how the cell
might affect design.
So you're writing a collision
detection system.
It's obvious that you cannot or
should not expect immediate
results from a collision
detection system, otherwise
you're going to be sitting and
syncing all the time for one
result and performance just goes
out the window, you may
as well just have a
serial program.
So you want to group results,
you want to group queries and
you want potentially, for those
queries to be deferred
so that you can store them, you
can just DMA them out and
then whatever process needed
then we'll come back and grab
them later.
So conceptually that's the
design you want to build into
a collision detection system,
which then in turn affects the
high-level design.
So AI, scripts, any game code
that might have previously
depended on a result being
immediately available, as in
they have characters that shoot
rays around the room to
decide what they're going to
do next or bullets that are
flying through the air or
whatever, can no longer make
that assumption.
So they have to be able to group
up their queries and
look them up later and
have other work
to do in the meantime.
So this is a perfect example
of how you cannot take old
code and move it to the PS3.
Because old code, serial code
would have definitely assumed
that the results were
immediately available because
honestly, that was the
fastest way to do it.
So on a separate issue, we have
SPU decomposition for the
geometry look up.
So from a high-level you have
your entire scene in the level
of the world or whatever and you
have the set of queries in
the case of static--
did I collide with
anything in the world?
Or you have a RAID that, where
does this RAID collide with
something in the world?
And so you have this problem of
you have this large sort of
memory database in main RAM
and you have the smallest
spew, which obviously cannot
read in the whole database,
analyze it, and spit
out the result.
It has to go back and forth
to main RAM in order
to build its result.
So the question is how do you
decompose the memory in the
first place to make
that at least
somewhat reasonably efficient?
The first sort of instinct I
think, based on history is
sort of the traditional scene
graph structures like BSP tree
or off tree or something
like that.
Particularly, on the SPU because
if TLB misses that
becomes really expensive, really
quickly when you're
basically hitting random
memory on every
single node on the tree.
So what you want to do is you
want to make that hierarchy as
flat as you possibly can.
If the leafs have to be bigger
that's fine because it turns
out it's much, much cheaper to
stream in a bigger group of--
as much data as you can fit into
the SPU and run through
it and make your decisions and
spit it back out than it is to
traverse the hierarchy.
So basically, the depth of your
hierarchy in your scene
database is completely
determined by how much data
you can fit into the
SPU by the maximum
size of the leaf node.
The rest of the dep is only
because you don't have any
other choice.
You know, And basically the same
thing goes with dynamic
geometry as you have geometry
moving around in the scene,
characters moving around
in the scene--
they basically need to update
themselves into their own
database, into their
own leaves and
they'll do this in groups.
And then when you query, you
basically want it to query as
many of those as possible,
as you can
possibly fit in at once.
So you could have sort of a
broad faced collision first,
where you have all of the groups
of characters that are
potentially maximum
in this leaf, so
bound and box or whatever.
So even though you could in
theory, in principle narrow
that down even more, the cost
for that, the cost for the
potential memory miss for that
is so high that you just want
to do a linear search through
as many as you
possibly can on SPU.
Does that make sense?
Procedural graphics--
so although we have a GPU on
the PlayStation 3, it does
turn out that the SPU
is a lot better at
doing a lot of things.
Things basically where
you create
geometry for RSX to render.
So particle system, dynamic
particle systems. Especially
where their systems have to
interact with the world in
some way, which will be much
more expensive on the GPU.
Sort of a dynamic systems
like cloth.
Fonts is actually really
interesting because typically
you'll just see bitmap
fonts in which
case are just textures.
But if you have a very complex
user interface then just the
size of the bitmap becomes
extreme and if you compressed
them they look terrible,
especially fonts.
Fonts need to look perfect.
So if you do do procedural
fonts, for example, two type
fonts, the cost of rendering
a font actually gets
significant.
And in this case, the SPU is
actually a great use for
rendering a procedural font.
Rendering textures
is basically the
same case as font.
Procedural textures like if you
do noise-based clouds or
something like that.
And parametric geometry, it's
like nurbs or subdivision
services or something like
that, is a perfect
case for the SPU.
Is there a question?
Geometry database, OK.
First thing scene graphs
are worthless.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So of those sort of
differnet conceptualized
paths, are you literally
swapping code in and out of
the SPUs with the data
many times per frame?
Or is it more of a static---
MIKE ACTON: OK, that's an
excellent question.
It totally depends.
I mean, in general through a
game or through, at least a
particular area of a game the
SPU set up is stable.
So if we decide you're going to
have this SPU dedicated to
physics for example, it is very
likely that that SPU is
stable and it's going to be
dedicated physics, at least
for some period of time through
the level or through
the zone or wherever it is.
Sometimes through
an entire game.
So there are going to be
elements of that where it's
sort of a well balanced
problem.
There's basically no way you're
going to get waste.
It's always going to be full,
it's always going to be busy.
Collision detection and physics
are the two things
that you'll never have
enough CPU to do.
You can always use more
and more CPU.
And basically, the rest can
be dynamically scheduled.
And the question of how to
schedule it, is actually an
interesting problem.
It's my opinion that sort of
looking for the universal
scheduler that solves all
problems and magically makes
everything work is a
total lost cause.
You have more than enough data
to work with and in your game
to decide how to schedule your
SPUs basically, manually.
And it's just not that
complicated.
We have six SPUs.
How to schedule six SPUs is just
not that complicated a
problem, you could write it
down on a piece of paper.
OK, so scene graphs are almost
always, universally a complete
waste time.
They store way too much data
for no apparent reason.
Store your databases
independently based on what
you're actually doing with
them, optimize your data
separately because you're
accessing it separately.
The only thing that should be
linking your sort of domain
object is a key that says all
right, we'll exist in this
database and the database
and this database.
But to have this sort of giant
structure that keeps all of
the data for each element in the
scene is about the poorest
performing you can imagine for
both cache and TLB and SPU
because you can't fit it in
individual node on the SPU.
I think I covered that.
Here's an interesting example,
so what you want to do is if
you have the table of queries
that you have-- bunch of
people over the course of a
frame say I want to know if I
collided with something.
And then if you basically make
a pre-sort pass on that and
basically, spatially sort these
guys together, so let's
say you have however many
you can fit in a SPU.
So you have four of these
queries together.
Although they might be a little
further apart then you
would hope, you could basically
create a baling box
through a single query on the
database that's the sum of all
of them and then as I said,
now you have a linear list
that you can just stream through
for all of them.
So even though it's doing more
work for any individual one,
the overhead is reduced so
significantly that the end
result is that it's
significantly faster.
And that's also what I mean by
multiple simultaneous lookups.
Basically you want to group
queries together, but make
sure that there's some
advantage to that.
By spatially pre-sorting them
there is an advantage to that
because it's more likely
that they will have
overlap in your queries.
So game logic.
Stuff that the cell would
affect in game logic.
State machines are
a good example.
If you defer your logic lines
and defer your results, SPUs
are amazingly perfect for
defining state machines.
If you expect your logic lines
to be immediately available
across the entire system, SPU
is absolutely horrid.
So if you basically write
buffers into your state
machines or your logic machines
then each SPU can be
cranking on multiple state
machines at once where all the
input and all the output lines
are assumed to be deferred and
it's just an extremely
straightforward process.
Scripting, so scripting
things like--
I don't know, lewis script
or C script or
something like that.
I mean, obviously the first
thing to look at is the size
of the interpreter.
Will it fit into an
SPU to begin with?
Another option to consider is,
can it be converted into SPU
code, either offline
or dynamically?
Because you'll find that most
off the shelf scripting
languages are scalar,
sequential scripting languages.
So all of a P code within the
scripting language itself
basically defines
scalar access.
So not only are you switching
on every byte to every two
bytes or whatever, so it's sort
of poorly performing code
from an SPU point of view, but
it's also poorly performing
code from a memory
point of view.
So I guess the question is
whether or not you can
optimize the script itself and
turn turn it into SPU code
that you can then dynamically
load or come up with a new
script that's just much more
friendly for the SPUs.
Another option if you have to
use a single, sort of scalar
scripting language like lua or
C script or whatever, if you
can run multiple streams
simultaneously so that while
you're doing these sort of
individual offline memory
lookups and reads and writes to
main memory, that once one
blocks you can start moving
on another one.
As long as there's no
dependencies between these two
scripts we should be able
to stream them both
simultaneously.
Motion control actually turns
out to be a critical problem
in games in general that's
often overlooked.
It's who controls the
motion in the game.
Is is the AI?
So is it the controller in
the case of the player?
I say, push forward, so
the guy moves forward.
Is that really what
controls it?
Or is it the physics?
So all the AI does is say, I
want to move forward, tells
the physic system I want to move
forward and the physics
tries to follow it.
Or is it the animation?
That you have the animators
actually put translation in
the animation, so is that
translation the thing that's
actually driving the motion and
everything else is trying
to follow it?
Turns out to be a surprisingly
difficult problem to solve and
every studio ends up with
their own solution.
I forget what point I was
making on how the cell
affected that decision.
But--
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: I think the point,
probably that I was trying to
make is that because you want
everything to be deferred
anyway, then the order does
become a clearer sort of
winner in that order.
Where you want the immediate
feedback from the controls,
the control leads the way.
You have the physics, which then
follows, perhaps, even a
frame behind that to say how
that new position is impacted
by the physical reality
of the world.
And then potentially a frame
behind that or half a frame
behind that you have the
animation system, which in
that case would just be
basically, a visual
representation of what's
going on rather
than leading anything.
It's basically an icon for
what's happening in the
physics and the AI.
The limitations of your system
are that it has to be deferred
and that it has to be
done in groups.
Basically, some of these sort of
really difficult decisions
have only one or two
obvious answers.
All right, well I wanted to dig
into animation a little
bit, so does anybody have any
questions on anything?
Any of the sort of the
high-level stuff that I've
covered up to this point?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So does the need for
deferral and breaking into
groups and staging, does this
need break the desire for the
higher-level programmers to
abstract what's going on at
the data engine level?
Or is that not quite
the issue?
MIKE ACTON: Well, let's
say we get a game
play programmer, right?
Fresh out of school, he's
taught in school, C
plus plus in school.
Taught to decompose the world
into sort of the main classes
and that they all communicate
through each other maybe
through messaging.
All right, well the first thing
we tell him is that all
that is complete crap.
None of that will actually
work in practice.
So in some sense, yes, there is
a sort of tendency for them
to want this interface, this
sort of clean abstraction, but
abstraction doesn't
have any value.
It doesn't make the game faster,
it doesn't make the
game cheaper.
It doesn't make--
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
PROFESSOR: There's a
bit of a religious.
Let's move on.
He has a lot of other
interesting things to say.
And we can get to
that question--
AUDIENCE: It sounds like
there's two completely
different communities involved
in the development.
There's the engine developers
and there's the higher-level--
MIKE ACTON: That's a fair
enough assessment.
There are different
communities.
There is a community of the game
play programmers and the
community of engine
programmers.
And they have different
priorities and they have
different experiences.
So yeah, in that way there
is a division.
PROFESSOR: I will
let you go on.
You said you had a lot
of interesting
information to cover.
MIKE ACTON: OK.
AUDIENCE: I can bitch
about that.
Don't worry.
MIKE ACTON: So just to get into
animation a little bit.
Let's start with trying to
build a simple animation
system and see what problems
come creep up as we're trying
to implement it on the cell.
So in the simplest case we
have a set of animation
channels defined for
a character, which
is made up of joints.
We're just talking about sort
of a simple hierarchical
transformation here.
And some of those channels
are related.
So in the case of rotation plus
translation plus scale
equals any individual joint.
So the first thing, typically
that you'll have to answer is
whether or not you want to do
euler or quaternion rotation.
Now the tendency I guess,
especially for new programmers
is to go with quaternion.
They're taught that gimbal
lock is a sort of
insurmountable problem that
only quaternion solves.
That's just simply not true.
I mean, gimbal lock
is completely
manageable in practice.
When you're trying to rotate
on three axes and two axes
rotate 90 degrees apart and
the third axis can't be
resolved or 180 degrees apart.
So you can't resolve one
of the axes, right?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: Yeah, it's where
it's impossible to resolve one
of the axes and that's
the nature of
euler sort of rotation.
But sort of a quaternion
rotation completely solves
that mathematical problem, it's
always resolvable and
it's not very messy at all.
I mean, from a sort of C
programmers perspective, it
looks clean, the math's clean,
everything's clean about it.
Unfortunately, it doesn't
compress very well at all.
Where if you used euler
rotation, which basically just
means that the individual
rotation for every axis.
So x rotation, y rotation,
z rotation.
That's much, much more
compressible because each one
of those axes can be
individually compressed.
It's very unlikely that you're
always rotating all three
axes, all the time, especially
in a human character.
It's much more likely that only
one axis is rotating on
any one given time and
so that makes it--
just without any change,
without any additional
compression-- it tends to make
it about 1/3 of the size.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: The animation
data.
So you have this frame of
animation, which is all these
animation channels, right?
And then over time you have
these different frames of
animation, right?
If you store-- for every joint,
for every rotation you
store a quaternion over time,
it's hard to compress across
time because you're basically,
essentially rotating all three
axes, all the time.
Well, with--
yeah?
All right.
So let's say, of course, the
next step is how do we store
the actual rotation itself?
Do we store it in cloth, double,
half precision, fixed
point precision?
Probably the national tendency
at this point would be to
store it in a floating point
number, but if you look at the
actual range of rotation, which
is extremely limited on
a character, on any particular
joint there are very few
joints that would even
rotate 180 degrees.
So a floating point
is overkill, by a
large margin on rotation--
for the range.
For the precision, however
it's fairly good.
Especially if you're doing very
small rotations over a
long period of time.
So probably a more balanced
approach would be to go with a
16 bit floating point from a
half format where you keep
most of the precision, but
you reduce the range
significantly.
There's also the potential for
going with an 8 bit floating
point format depending
on the kind of
animation that you're doing.
And I'll probably have this on
another slide, but it really
depends on how close--
how compressible a joint is
depends on how close to the
root it is.
The further away from the root
the less it matters.
So the joint at your fingertip,
you can compress a
whole lot more because it
doesn't matter as much, it's
not going to affect
anything else.
Where a joint at the actual
root, the smallest change in
motion will affect the entire
system in animation and will
make it virtually impossible for
you to line up animations
with each other, so that that
particular joint needs to be
nearly perfect.
And how do you store rotation?
Do you store them in degrees,
radians, or normalized?
I have seen people store
them in degrees.
I don't understand why you
would ever do that.
It's just adding math
to the problem.
Radians is perfectly fine if
you're using off the shelf
trigonometric functions-
tan, sine whatever.
But typically, if you're going
to optimize those functions
yourself anyway, it's going to
be much more effective go with
a normalized rotational value.
So basically between
zero and 1.
Makes it a lot easier to do
tricks based on the circle.
Basically you can just take the
fractional value and just
deal with that.
So normalized rotation is
generally the way to go and
normalizing a half precision is
probably the even bet for
how you would store.
So looking at what we need to
fit into an SPU if we're going
to running to an end machine.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You talked a lot about
compressing because of
the way it's impacting data,
what's the key driver of that?
MIKE ACTON: The SPU has
very little space.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it's just
the amount of space.
MIKE ACTON: Yeah, well OK.
There's two factors really,
in all honesty.
So starting with the SPU.
That you have to be able
to work through
this data on the SPU.
But you also have the
DMA transfer itself.
The SPU can actually calculate
really, really fast, right?
I mean, that's the
whole point.
So if you can transfer less
data, burn through it a little
bit to expand it, it's
actually a huge win.
And on top of that we have a
big, big game and only 256
megs of main ram.
And the amount of geometry that
people require from a
current generation game or
next generation game has
scaled up way more than the
amount of memory we've been
given, so we've only been given
eight times as much
memory as we had in the
previous generation.
People expect significantly more
than eight times as much
geometry on the screen and
where do we store that?
We have the Blu-Ray, we can't
be streaming everything off
the disc all the time, which
is to another point.
You have 40 gigs of data
on your disc, but
only 256 megs of RAM.
So there's this sort of a
series of compression,
decompression to keep
everything--
basically, think of RAM
as your L3 cache.
So we look at what we want
to store on an SPU.
Basically, the goal of this is
we want to get an entire
animation for a particular
skeleton on an SPU so that we
can transform the skeleton
and output the
resulting joint data.
So let's look at how big
that would have to be.
So first we start with the basic
nine channels per joint.
That's not assuming and again,
you'd probably have additional
channels, like foot step
channels and sound channels
and other sort of animation
channels to help
actually make a game.
In this case, we just want
to animate the character.
So we have rotation times 3,
translations times 3, and
scales times 3.
So the first thing to drop and
this will cover, this will
reduce your data by 70%, is
all the uniform channels.
So any data that doesn't
actually change across the
entire length of
the animation.
It may not be zero, but it could
be just one thing, one
value that doesn't
change across
length of the animation.
So you pull all the uniform
channels out.
And most things that's going to
be scale, for example, most
joints don't scale.
Although occasionally they do.
And translation, in a human our
joints don't translate.
However, when you actually
animate a character in order
to get particular effects, in
order to make it look more
human you do end up needing
to translate joints.
So we can reduce, but in order
to that we need to build a
map, basically, a table of
these uniform channels.
So now we know this table of
uniform channels has to be
stored in the SPU along with
now the remaining actual
animation data.
Of course, multiplied by
the number of joints.
So now we have what
is essentially
raw animation data.
So for the sake of argument,
let's say the animation data
has been baked out by
Maya or whatever
at 30 frames a second.
We've pulled out the uniform
data, so now for the joints
that do move we have these
curves over time of the entire
length of the animation.
The problem is if that animation
is 10 seconds long,
it's now way too big to fit in
the SPU by a large margin.
So how do we sort of compress
it down so that it
actually will fit?
Again, just first of all, the
easiest thing to do to start
with is just do simple curve
fitting to get rid of the
things that don't need to be
there that you can easily
calculate out.
And again, the closer that you
are to the root, the tighter
that fits need to be.
Conversely, the further away you
are from the root, you can
loosen up the restrictions a
little bit and have a little
bit looser fit on the
curve and compress
a little bit more.
So if you're doing a curve
fitting with the simple
spline, basically you have to
store your time values in the
places that were calculated.
Part of the problem is now you
have sort of these individual
scalars with time can be
randomly spread throughout the
entire animation.
So any point where there's
basically a knot in the curve,
there's a time value.
And none of these knots are
going to line up with each
other in any of these
animation channels.
So in principle, if you wanted
to code this you would have to
basically say, what is time
right now and loop through
each of these scalar values,
find out where time is,
calculate the postition
on the curve and then
spit out the result.
So one, you still have to have
the unlimited length of data
and two, you're looping through
scalar values on the
SPU, which is really
actually, horrible.
So we want to find a way
to solve that problem.
Probably the most trivial
solution is
just do spline segemnts.
You lose some compressibility,
but it solves the problem.
Basically you split up the
spline into say, sections of
16 knots and you just do that.
And in order to do that you just
need a table, you need to
add a table that says what the
range of time are in each of
those groups of 16 knots
for every channel.
So when you're going to
transform the animation, first
you load this table in, you say,
what's my time right now
at time, t?
You go and say which blocks,
which segments of the spline
you need to load in for each
channel, you load those in.
So now you have basically one
section of the spline, which
is too big probably for the
current t, but it covers what
t you're actually in.
So one block of spline for
every single channel.
So the advantage of this, now
that the spline is sorted into
sections is that rather than
having all the spline data
stored, sort of linearly, you
can now reorder the blocks so
that the spline data from
different channels is actually
tiled next to each other.
So that when you actually go
to do a load it's much more
likely because you know you're
going to be requesting all
these channel at once and all
on the same time, t, you can
find a more or less, optimal
ordering that will allow more
of these group things to be
grouped in the same cache or
at least the same page.
And the advantage of course
again, is now the length of
animation makes absolutely
no difference at all.
The disadvantage is its less
compressible because you can
only basically compress this one
section of the curve, but
a huge advantage is it solves
the scalar loop problem.
So now you can take four of
these scalar values all with a
fixed known number of knots in
it and just loop through all
of the knots.
In principle you could search
through and find a minimum
number of knots to look through
for each one of the
scalars, but in practice it's
much faster just to loop
through all four simultaneously
for all 16
knots and just throw away the
results that are invalid as
you're going through it.
That way you can use the
SPU instruction set.
You can load quadwords, store
quadwords, and do everything
in the minimum single
loop, which you
can completely unroll.
Does anybody have the time?
PROFESSOR: It's [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: So I'm OK.
PROFESSOR: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In
context do you make like
rendering the animation or it
seems like there would be a blow
to whatever you're doing
on the SPUs.
MIKE ACTON: Basically the SPUs
are taking this channel
animation data and baking it
out into-- well, in the
easiest case baking
it out into a 4 by
4 matrix per joint.
AUDIENCE: So the output
time's much bigger
than the input time?
I mean, you're compressing
the input by animation?
MIKE ACTON: No, the output size
is significant, but it's
much smaller.
PROFESSOR: [OBSCURED]
AUDIENCE: So the animation
data it's [OBSCURED]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MIKE ACTON: No.
I was just outputting the
joint information.
PROFESSOR: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: Independently we
have this skimming problem.
Independently there's
a rendering problem.
This is just baking animation.
This is purely animation
channel problem.
PROFESSOR: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: OK, I'm just going
to skip through this because
this could take a long
time to talk about.
Basically, what I wanted to say
here was let's take the
next step with animation,
let's add
some dynamic support.
The easiest thing to do is just
create a second uniform
data table that you then
blend with the first
one and that one.
In principle, is basically all
of the channels and then now a
game play programmer can go and
individually set any of those.
So they can tweak the head or
tweak the elbow or whatever.
And that's definitely
compressible because it's very
unlikely thet're going to be
moving all the joints at once.
You can create a secondary map
that says, this is the number
of joints that are dynamic, this
is how they map to the
uniform values.
But then once you add any kind
of dynamic support, you have
now complicated the problem
significantly.
Because now in reality, what
you need are constraints.
You need to be able to have a
limit to how high the head can
move because what's going to
happen is although you could
just say the head could only
move so much, if that movement
is algorithmic, so let's
say follow a
character or whatever--
it is going to go outside
of reasonable
constraints really quickly.
So it's much cleaner and simpler
to support that on the
engine side, so basically define
constraints for the
joints and then let the
high-level code point
wherever they want.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: Yeah.
Yeah, you can have max change
over time so it only can move
so fast. The max range of
motion, the max acceleration
is actually a much harder
problem because it implies
that you need to store the
change over time, which we're
not actually storing.
Which would probably blow
our memory on the SPU.
So as far as impacting
animation, I would immediately
throw out max acceleration if an
animator were to come to me
and say, this is a feature
that I wanted.
I would say, it's unlikely
because it's unlikely we can
fit it on the SPU.
Whereas, on the PC, it might
be a different story.
And blending information,
how you blend
these things together.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: OK.
So as far as mixing, there's
plenty of additional problems
in mixing animation.
Phase matching, so for example,
you have a running
and a walk.
Basically all that means is if
you were going to blend from a
run to a walk you kind of want
to blend in basically the
essentially same leg position.
Because if you just blend from
the middle of an animation to
the beginning of the animation,
it's unlikely the
legs are going to match and for
the transition time you're
going to see the scissoring
of the legs.
Which you see that in plenty
of games, but especially in
next generation, especially
as characters look more
complicated they are expected
to act more complicated.
Transitions handling either
programmatic transitions
between animations, so we have
an animation that's standing
and animation that's crouching
and with constraints, move
them down; or artist
driven animated
transitions and/or both.
Translation matching
is actually
an interesting problem.
So you have an animation that's
running and you have an
animation that's walking.
They both translate obviously,
at different speeds,
nonlinearly and you want to
slowly run down into a walk,
but you have to match these sort
of nonlinear translations
as his feet are stepping
onto the ground.
Turns out to be a really
difficult problem to get
perfectly right, especially if
you have eye key on the feet
where he's walking on the ground
or maybe walking uphill
or downhill and the translation
is being affected
by the world.
In a lot of cases you'll see
people pretty much just ignore
this problem.
But it is something to consider
going forward and
this is something that we would
consider how to solve,
regardless of whether or
not we could get it in.
As far as actually rendering
the geometry goes, you now
have your sort of matrices
of joints and you have--
let's say you want to send those
to the GPU along with
the geometry to skin
and render.
Now the question is, do
you single or double
buffer those joints?
Because right now basically, the
GPU can be reading these
joints in parallel
to when you're
actually outputting them.
So the traditional approach or
the easiest approach is just
to double buffer the joints.
So just output into a different
buffer that the R6
is reading from.
It's one frame or half a frame
behind, doesn't much matter.
But it also doubles now the
space of your joints.
One advantage that games have
is that a frame is a well
defined element in the games.
We know what needs to happen
across the course of a frame.
So these characters need to be
rendered, the collisions of
this background needs
to happen, physics
need to happen here.
So you can within a frame, set
it up so that the update from
the SPUs and the read from the
GPU can never overlap.
Even without any kind of
synchronization or lock, it
can be a well known fact that
it's impossible for these two
things because there's actually
something in the
middle happening that has its
own synchronization primitive.
That will allow you to do single
buffering of the data.
But it does require
more organization.
Especially if you're doing it
on more than just one case.
So you have all these things
that you want single buffered,
so you need to organize them
within the frames so they're
never updating and reading
at the same time.
So I'll make this the last
point I'll make.
Optimization, one of the things
that you'll hear, save
optimization till the end.
My point here being is if you
save optimization till the
end, you don't know how to
do it because you haven't
actually practiced it.
If you haven't practiced it
you don't know what to do.
So it will take much longer.
You should always be optimizing
in order to
understand, when it actually
counts, what to do.
And the fact that real
optimization does impact the
design all the way up.
Optimization of the hardware
impacts how an engine is
designed to be fast does impact
the data, it impacts
how game play needs to be
written, high-level code needs
to be called.
So if you save optimization till
last, what you're doing
is completely limiting what
you can optimize.
And the idea that it's the root
of all evil certainly
didn't come from a game
developer, I have to say.
Anyway, that's it.
I hope that was helpful.
PROFESSOR: Any questions?
I think it's very interesting
because there is a lot of
things you learn at MIT.
Forget everything you learned
so I think there's a very
interesting perspective in there
and for some of us it's
kind of hard to even digest a
little bit, but Question?
AUDIENCE: Call of Duty 3 came
out on the Xbox and on the
PS3, is Call of Duty 3 on the
PS3 just running on the GPU
then or is it--
MIKE ACTON: No, it's very
likely using the SPUs.
I mean, I don't know.
I haven't looked at the source
code, but I suspect that it's
using the SPUs.
How efficiently it's
using them is an
entirely different question.
But it's easy to take the most
trivial things right, say you
do hot spot analysis on your
sequential code and say, OK,
well I can grab this section of
thing and put it on the SPU
right and just the heaviest
hitters and
put them on the SPU.
That's pretty easy to do.
It's taking it to the next level
though, and to really
have sort of the next
gen of game--
now there's nowhere
to go from there.
There's nowhere to go from that
analysis, you've already
sort of hit the limit of what
you can do with that.
It has to be redesigned.
So I don't know what they're
doing honestly and certainly
I'm being recorded so--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: You guys have shipped
a game, on the PS3?
MIKE ACTON: Yeah, it
was on action list.
AUDIENCE: OK, so that was
more like the [OBSCURED]
games and whatever You seem to
talk a lot about all these
things you've had to redo.
What else is there--
games look better as a console
was built on, what else is
there that you guys plan on
changing as far as working
with the cell processor,
or do you think
you've got it all ready?
MIKE ACTON: Oh, no.
There's plenty of work.
There's plenty more
to be optimized.
It's down to cost in scheduling
those things.
I mean, we have a team of
people who now really
understand the platform and
whereas a lot of what went
into previous titles was mixed
with learning curve.
So there's definitely a
potential for going back and
improving things and making
things better.
That's what a cycle of game
development is all about.
I mean, games at the end of the
lifetime of PlayStation 3
will look significantly better
than release titles.
That's the way it always is.
AUDIENCE: The head of Sony
computer and gaming said that
PS3 pretty soon would
be customizable.
You're be able to get different
amounts of RAM and whatnot.
MIKE ACTON: Well, I think in
that case he was talking
specifically about a PS3 based,
like Tivo kind of weird
media thing, which has nothing
to do with us.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: We're not stuck.
That's what we have. I mean,
I don't see it as stuck.
I would much rather have the--
I mean, that's what console
development is about, really.
We have a machine, we have a set
of limitations of it and
we can push that machine over
the lifetime of the platform.
If it changes out from under us,
it becomes PC development.
AUDIENCE: Are you allowed
to use the
seven SPUs or are you--
[OBSCURED]
PROFESSOR: [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: I don't know how
much I can answer this just
from NDA point-of-view.
But let's say hypothetically,
there magically became more
SPUs on the PS3, right?
Probably nothing would happen.
The game has to be optimized
for the minimum case, so
nothing would change.
Anything else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So what's the
development life cycle like
for the engine part
of the game.
And I don't assume you start by
prototyping in higher-level
mechanisms. Then you'll
completely miss the design for
performance aspects of it.
How do you build up from
empty [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: No, you don't
start with an empty.
That's the perspective
difference.
You don't start with code,
code's not important.
Start with the data.
You sit down with an artist
and they say, what
do you want to do?
And then you look at the data.
What does that data look like?
What does this animation
data look like?
PROFESSOR: Data size matters.
[OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: Right.
We have to figure out how
to make it smaller.
But it all starts
with the data.
It all starts with that concept
of what do we want to
see on the screen?
What do we even want to
hear on the speakers?
What kind of effects
do we want.
And actually look at that from
the perspective of the content
creator and what they're
generating and what we can do
with that data.
Because game development is just
this black box between
the artists and the screen.
We're providing a transformation
engine that
takes the vision of the
designers and the artists and
just transforming it and
spitting it on to screen.
So where you really need
to start is with the
source of the data.
AUDIENCE: You've been doing game
developoment for 11 years
now is what you said.
Have you had a favorite
platform
and a nightmare platform?
MIKE ACTON: I've been pretty
much with the PlayStation
platform since there was a
PlayStation platform and I
don't know, it's hard to get
perspective because you're
getting it and you always really
love plarform you're
working on.
So it's hard.
I mean, it's hard to
get perspective.
In the program where I am today
is not the same program
where I was 10 years ago.
Personally, right now my
favorite plarform is PS3.
PROFESSOR: So when put it in
perspective, there are already
some platforms that on the first
time round, [COUGHING],
it's like cost of development.
So one platform that as time
goes we have [OBSCURED]
MIKE ACTON: Well, like with the
PS3, some of the things
that I like about the PS3, which
is sort of a different
question are the fact that the
cell is much more public than
any other platform
has ever been.
With IBM's documentation, with
Toshiba's support and Sony
support, I've never had a
platform where I can get up on
a website and actually talk
about it outside of NDA.
And that for me is an
amazing change.
Where I can go and talk to other
people-- exactly like
this group here- that have
used the same exact
platform I've used.
That's never been able
to happen before.
Even on PS2, for quite a long
part of the lifespan, even
though there was a Linux
eventually on the PS2,
virtually everything was covered
by NDA because there
was no independent release
of information.
So that's one of the great
things about PS3 is the public
availability of cell.
PROFESSOR: Thank you very much
for coming all the way from
California and giving
us some insight.